Now, the U.S House Foreign Affairs Committee...
...has voted to give President Joe Biden new powers...
...for an outright ban of TikTok and other social media apps.
Lawmakers voted 26 to 16 to approve the measure.
Republican committee chair, Michael McCall, sponsored it.
Democrats on the committee opposed the bill.
TikTok is used by more than 100 million Americans.
The measure would need to be passed by the full House and U.S. Senate...
...before it can go to Biden.
TikTok has come under increased scrutiny on both sides of the Atlantic...
...as Western countries take a critical look at the Chinese company's reach...
...and the security risks it may pose.
Canada's Electronic Spy Agency, for instance,...
...is now watching for security threats from TikTok.
Canada has banned TikTok from government phones,...
...saying the Chinese app carries an unacceptable risk to privacy and security.
Ottawa will also block federal employees from downloading the app in the future.
We're making the decision that, for government employees, for government equipment...
...it is better to not have them access TikTok...
...because of the concerns that people have in terms of safety.
This may be a first step, it may be the only step we need to take.
But every step of the way, we're going to be making sure we're keeping Canadians safe.
In the U.S., federal agencies have 30 days to remove the Chinese owned video platform...
...from all government-issued devices.
Contractors must comply within 90 days, the White House said on Monday.
The decisions further strain Sino Western relations...
...which have been troubled in recent years.
Most recently over Western accusations that China could use data to threaten cybersecurity.